hi good morning Hank it's uh Friday I
think today I'm not going to do a real
video I'm going to do a live show video
but nerdfighters before you start to
punish me I have permission from Hank to
do this it's going to save me a lot of
time not to have to edit a video today
and I appreciate your patience but I am
going to read to you the first chapter
of The Fault in Our Stars today which is
something I wanted to I wanted to do for
a long time but I and I tried to do once
like a few months ago but then I had to
change about I wanted to change a bunch
of stuff so I ended up deleting that
live show but this live show is here to
stay I'm sorry that it's going to be
longer than 4 minutes but you know it's
a long book um
and I'm gonna start reading to you now
unless there's anything that I forgot to
say um yeah oh I guess just the only
other thing is but for those of you who
are watching live can you please explain
to people who are coming into the room
for the first time that they haven't
missed the entire thing because it's
going to be recorded and they can go
back and listen to the first chapter at
their leisure you know they can listen
to it a hundred times if they want it's
a little weird but you can do that
so this book is called The Fault in Our
Stars and it is dedicated to my friend
Esther Earl ah and then after the
dedication comes the you know how like
pretentious novels always start with you
know pretentious quotations from
pretentious novels this book is no
exception
starts with an epigraph as the tide
washed in the Dutch tulip man faced the
ocean conjoin er rejoinder poisoner
concealer Revelator look at it he said
rising up and rising down taking
everything with it what's that
and I asked water the Dutchman said well
and time Peter Van Houten an imperial
affliction then there's an author's note
which I will read to you now author's
note this is not so much an author's
note as an author's reminder of what was
printed in small type a few pages ago
this book is a work of
action I made it up neither novels nor
their readers benefit from attempts to
divine whether any facts hide inside of
a story such efforts attack the very
idea that made-up stories can matter
which is sort of the foundational
assumption of our species I appreciate
your cooperation in this matter and now
begins the actual book The Fault in Our
Stars I'm reading from a page proof by
the way so there may be some mistakes
but hopefully not if there are I'm going
to have to stop reading and correct
myself chapter one
late in the winter of my sixteenth year
my mother decided I was depressed
presumably because I rarely left the
house spent quite a lot of time in bed
read the same book over and over ate
infrequently and devoted quite a bit of
my abundant free time to thinking about
death whenever you read a cancer booklet
or website or whatever they always list
depression among the side effects of
cancer but in fact depression is not a
side effect of cancer depression is a
side effect of dying cancer is also a
side effect of dying almost everything
is really what my mom believed I
required treatment so she took me to see
my regular doctor Jim who agreed that I
was veritably swimming in a paralyzing
and totally clinical depression and that
therefore my meds should be adjusted and
also I should attend a weekly support
group this support group featured a
rotating cast of characters in various
states of tumor driven unwellness why
did the cast rotate a side effect of
dying
the support group of course was
depressing as hell it meant every
Wednesday in the basement of a
stonewalled Episcopal Church shaped like
a cross we all sat right in the middle
of the cross where the two boards would
have met where the Heart of Jesus would
have been I noticed this because Patrick
the support group leader and only person
over 18 in the room talked about the
Heart of Jesus every freaking meeting
all about how we as young cancer
survivors were sitting right in Christ's
very sacred heart and whatever so here's
how it went in God's heart the six or
seven or
of us walked or wheeled in grazed at a
decrepit selection of cookies and
lemonade sat down in the circle of trust
and listened to Patrick recount for the
thousandth time his depressingly
miserable life story how he had cancer
in his balls and they thought he was
going to die but then he didn't die and
now here he is a full-grown adult in a
church basement in the 137th nicest city
in America divorced addicted to video
games mostly friendless eking out a
meager living by exploiting his cancer
tastic past slowly working his way
toward a master's degree that will not
improve his career prospects waiting as
we all do for the sword of Damocles to
give him the relief that he escaped lo
those many years ago when cancer took
both of his nuts but spared what only
the most generous soul would call his
life and you too might be so lucky then
we introduced ourselves
name age diagnosis and how we're doing
today I'm hazel I'd say when they'd get
to me 16000 long-settled colony in my
lungs and I'm doing okay by the way I
should mention that the narrator of this
novel is a girl named hazel grace
Lancaster and she's 16 and as you may
have noticed I'm a 34 year old man
that's a little bit awkward I know like
having a 34 year old man read to you in
the voice of a 16 year old girl so just
get over it just let me read you the
story sorry I'm not going to say and
then I took off my bra or anything at
least in this chapter um all right once
we got around the circle Patrick always
asked if anyone wanted to share and then
began the circle jerk of support
everyone talking about fighting and
battling and winning and shrinking and
scanning to be fair to Patrick he let us
talk about dying too but most of them
weren't dying most would live into
adulthood as Patrick had which meant
there was quite a lot of competitiveness
about it with everybody wanting to beat
not only cancer itself but also the
other people in the room like I realized
that this is irrational but when they
tell you that you have say a 20% chance
of living
five years the math kicks in and you
figure that's one in five so you look
around and think as any healthy person
would I got out last four of these
bastards
the only redeeming facet of support
group was this kid named Isaac a long
faced skinny guy with straight blond
hair swept over one eye
his eyes were the problem he had some
fantastically improbable eye cancer one
eye had been cut out when he was a kid
and now we were the kind of thick
glasses that made both of his both his
eyes the real one and the glass one
tretter naturally huge like his whole
head was basically just this fake eye
and this real eye staring at you from
what I could gather on the rare
occasions when Isaac shared with the
group a recurrence had placed his
remaining eye in some mortal peril Isaac
and I communicated almost exclusively
through size each time someone discussed
anti-cancer diets are snorting up ground
shark-fin or whatever
he'd glanced over at me and sigh ever so
slightly I'd shake my head
microscopically and exhale in response
so support group blue and after a few
weeks I grew to be rather kicking and
screaming about the whole affair in fact
on the Wednesday I made the acquaintance
of Augustus waters I tried my level best
to get out of support group while
sitting on the couch with my mom in the
third leg of a 12-hour marathon of the
previous seasons America's Next Top
Model which admittedly I had already
seen but still me I refused to attend
support group mom you know what are the
symptoms of depression is disinterest in
activities me please just let me watch
America's Next Top Model it's an
activity mom television is a passivity
me Oh mom please mom hazel you're a
teenager you're not a little kid anymore
you need to make friends get out of the
house live your life me if you wanted to
be a teenager don't send me to support
group buy me a fake ID so I can go to
clubs and drink vodka and take pot mom
you don't take pop for starters me see
that's the kind of thing I would know if
you got me a fake ID mom you're going to
support group me
mom hazel you deserve a life that shut
me up although I failed to see how
attendance at support group met the
definition of life still I agreed to go
after negotiating the right to record
the one point five episodes of America's
Next Top Model I'd be missing I went to
support group for the same reason that
I'd once allowed nurses with a mere 18
months of graduate education to poison
me with exotically named chemicals I
wanted to make my parents happy there is
only one thing in this world shittier
than biting it from cancer when you're
16 and that one thing is having a kid
who bites it from cancer mom pulled into
the circular driveway behind the church
at 456 I've pretended to fiddle with my
oxygen tank for a second just to kill
time you want me to carry it for you no
it's fine I said the cylindrical green
tank only weighed a few pounds and I had
this little steel cart to wheel it
around behind me it delivered two liters
of oxygen to me each minute through a
Canela a transparent tube that split
just beneath my neck wrapped behind my
ears and then reunited in my nostrils
the contraption was necessary because my
lungs sucked at being lungs I love you
she said as I got out you too mom see
you tics make friends she said through
the rolled down window as I walked away
I didn't want to take the elevator
because taking the elevator is a last
days kind of activity at support group
so I took the stairs I grabbed a cookie
and poured some lemonade into a Dixie
cup and then turned around a boy was
staring at me I was quite sure I'd never
seen him before long and lean Lee
muscular he dwarfed the molded plastic
elementary school chair he was sitting
in mahogany hair straight and short
he looked my age maybe a year older and
he sat with his tailbone against the
edge of the chair his posture
aggressively pour one hand half in a
pocket of dark jeans I looked away
suddenly conscious of my myriad
insufficiencies I was wearing old jeans
which had once been tight but now sagged
in weird places and a yellow t-shirt
advertising a band I didn't even like
anymore also my hair I had this pageboy
haircut and I hadn't even bothered to
like
furthermore I had ridiculously fat
chipmunk cheeks of sight effective
treatment I looked like a normally
proportioned person with a balloon for a
head that wasn't even to mention the
cankle situation and yet I cut a glance
to him and his eyes were still on me it
occurred to me why they call it eye
contact I walked into the circle and sat
down next to Isaac two seats away from
the boy I glanced again he was still
watching them look let me just say it he
was hot a non hot boy stares at you
relentlessly and it is at best awkward
and at worst a form of assault but a hot
boy well I pulled out my phone and
clicked it so it would display the time
4:59 the circle filled in with the
unlucky 12 to 18 s and then Patrick
started us out with the serenity prayer
god grant me the serenity to accept the
things I cannot change the courage to
change the things I can and the wisdom
to know the difference the guy was still
staring at me I felt rather blushy
finally I decided that the proper
strategy was to stare back boys do not
have a monopoly on the staring business
after all
so I looked him over as Patrick
acknowledged for the thousandth time his
ball business etc and soon it was a
staring contest after a while the voice
smiled and then finally his blue eyes
glanced away when he looked back at me I
flicked my eyebrows up to say I win he
shrugged
Patrick continued and then finally it
was time for the introductions
Isaac perhaps you'd like to go first
today I know you're facing a challenging
week yeah Isaac said I'm Isaac I'm 17
and it's looking like I have to get
surgery in a couple weeks after which
I'll be blind not to complain or
anything because I know a lot of us have
it worse but yeah I mean being blind
does sort of suck my girlfriend helps
though and friends like Augustus he
nodded toward the boy who now had a name
so yeah
Isaac continued he was looking at his
hands which he folded into each other
like the top of a teepee there's nothing
you can do about it we're here for you
Isaac
Patrick's and let Isaac hear it guys and
then we all in a monotone said we're
here for you Isaac Michael was next
he was 12 he had leukemia he'd always
had leukemia he was okay or so he said
he'd taken the elevator Lida was 16 and
plenty pretty enough to be the object of
the hot boys I she was a regular in a
long remission from appendiceal cancer
which I hadn't previously known existed
she said as she had every other time I'd
attended support group that she felt
strong which felt like bragging to me as
the oxygen drizzling nubs tickled my
nostrils there were five others before
they got to him he smiled a little when
his turn came his voice was low smoky
and dead sexy my name is Augustus waters
he said I'm 17 I had just a little touch
of osteosarcoma about a year and a half
ago but I'm just here today at Isaac's
request and how are you feeling
asked Patrick oh I'm grand Augustus
waters smiled with a corner of his mouth
I'm on a roller coaster that only goes
up friend when it was my turn I said my
name is hazel I'm 16 Cyril with medicine
my lungs
I'm okay the hour proceeded apace fights
were recounted battles won amid Wars
sure to be lost hope was clung to
families were both celebrated and
denounced it was agreed that friends
just didn't get it
tears were shed comfort proffered
neither Augustus waters nor I spoke
again until Patrick said Augustus
perhaps you'd like to share your fears
with the group my fears yes I fear
oblivion he said without a moment's
pause
I feared like the proverbial blind man
who's afraid of the dark too soon Isaac
said cracking a smile Oh was that
insensitive Augustus and I'm sorry I can
be really blind to other people's
feelings
Isaac was laughing but Patrick raised a
chastening finger and said Augustus
please let's return to you and your
struggles
you said you fear oblivion I did
Augustus answered patrick seemed lost
would uh would anyone like to speak to
that i hadn't been in proper school in
three years
my parents were my two best friends my
third best friend was an author who did
not know I existed I was a fairly shy
person
not the hand-raising type and yet just
this once I decided to speak I have
raised my hand and Patrick his delight
evident immediately said hazel I was I'm
sure he assumed opening up becoming part
of the group I looked over at Augustus
waters who looked back at me you could
almost see through his eyes they were so
blue there will come a time I said when
all of us are dead all of us there will
come a time when there are no human
beings remaining to remember that anyone
ever existed or that our species ever
did anything there will be no one left
to remember Aristotle or Cleopatra let
alone you everything that we did and
built and wrote and thought and
discovered will be forgotten and all of
this i gestured encompassing Lee will
have been for naught maybe that time is
coming soon and maybe its millions of
years away but even if we survive the
collapse of our Sun we will not survive
forever there was time before organisms
experienced consciousness and there will
be time after and if the inevitability
of human oblivion worries you I
encourage you to ignore it God knows
that's what everyone else does I'd
learned this from my after mentioned
third best friend Peter Van Houten the
reclusive author of the novel an
imperial affliction the book that was as
close a thing as I had to a Bible Peter
Van Houten was the only person I'd ever
come across who seemed to a understand
what it's like to be dying and be not
have died after I finished there was
quite a long period of silence as I
watched a smile spread all the way
across Augustus his face not the crooked
little smile of the boy trying to be
sexy while he stared at me but his real
smile too big for his face god damned
Augustus said quietly aren't you
something else neither of us said
anything for the rest of support-group
at the end we all had to hold hands and
Patrick led us in a prayer Lord Jesus
Christ we are gathered here in your
heart literally in your heart as cancer
survivors you and you alone know us as
we know ourselves guide us to life and
the light through our times of trial we
pray for Isaac's eyes for Michaels and
Jamie's blood for Augustus
bones for Hazel's lungs for James's
throat we pray that you might heal us
and that we might feel your love and
your peace which passes all
understanding and we remember in our
hearts those whom we knew and loved who
have gone home to you Maria and Kaede
and Joseph and Hailey and Abigail and
Angelina and Taylor and Gabriel it was a
long list the world contains a lot of
dead people and while Patrick droned on
reading from the list from a sheet of
paper because it was too long to
memorize I kept my eyes closed trying to
think prayerfully but mostly imagining
the day when my name would find its way
onto that list all the way at the end
when everyone had stopped listening when
Patrick was finished we said this stupid
mantra together living our best life
today and it was over the Gustus waters
pushed himself out of his chair and
walked over to me his gait was crooked
like his smile he towered over me but he
kept his distance so I wouldn't have to
Crane my neck to look him in the eye
what's your name he asked hazel no your
full name um hazel grace Lancaster he
was just about to say something else
when Isaac walked up hold on Augustus
said raising a finger and turned to
Isaac that was actually worse than you
made it out to be I told you it was
bleak why do you bother with it I don't
know kind of helps Augustus leaned in so
he thought I couldn't hear she's a
regular
I couldn't hear Isaac's comment but
Augustus responded I'll say he clasped
Isaac by both shoulders and then took a
half step away from him tell hazel about
Clinic
Isaac leaned a hand against the snack
table and focused his huge eye on me all
right so I went to clinic this morning
and I was telling my surgeon that I'd
rather be death than blind and he said
it doesn't work that way and I was like
yeah I realize it doesn't work that way
I'm just saying that I'd rather be deaf
and blind if I had the choice which I
realize I don't have and he said well
the good news is you won't be deaf and I
was like yeah hey thanks for explaining
that my eye cancer isn't going to make
me deaf I feel so fortunate that an
intellectual giant like yourself would
deign to operate on me he sounds like a
winner I said I'm
try to give me some eye cancer just so I
can make that guy's acquaintance good
luck with that Isaac said all right I
should go Monica's waiting for me
upstairs I got a look at her a lot while
I can counter insurgents tomorrow
Augustus asked definitely Isaac turned
and ran up the stairs taking them two at
a time
Augustus waters turned to me literally
he said literally I asked
we are literally in the Heart of Jesus
he said I thought we were in a church
basement but we are literally in the
Heart of Jesus
someone she told Jesus I said I mean
it's got to be dangerous storing
children with cancer in your heart I
would tell him myself
Augustus said but unfortunately I am
literally stuck inside of his heart so
he won't be able to hear me I laughed he
shook his head just looking at me what I
asked nothing he said why are you
looking at me like that
Augustus half smiled because you're
beautiful I enjoy looking at beautiful
people and I decided a while ago not to
deny myself the simpler pleasures of
existence a brief awkward silence ensued
Augustus plowed through I mean
particularly given that as you so
deliciously pointed out all of this will
end in Oblivion and everything I kind of
scoffed her side or exhaled in a way
that was meant to be vaguely coffee and
then said I'm not beauty like a
millennial Natalie Portman like V for
Vendetta and Natalie Portman never seen
it I said really yes
pixie haired gorgeous girl dislikes
Authority and can't help but fall for a
boy she knows his trouble it's your
autobiography as far as I can tell his
every syllable flirted honestly he kind
of turned me on I didn't even know that
guys could turn me on
not like in real life a younger girl
walked past us how's it going ELISA
he asked she smiled and mumbled hi
Augustus memorial people he explained
memorial was the big Research Hospital
where do you go childrens I said my
voice smaller than I expected it to be
he nodded the conversation seemed over
well I said nodding vaguely toward the
steps that led us out of the literal
Heart of Jesus I tilted my card onto its
wheels and started walking he limped
beside me so see
next time maybe I asked you should see
it he said V for Vendetta I mean okay I
said I'll look it up no with me at my
house now he said I stopped walking I
hardly know you Augustus waters you
could be an ax murderer he nodded true
enough hazel grace he walked past me his
shoulders filling out his green knit
polo shirt his back straight his steps
lilting just slightly to the right as he
walked steady and confident on what I
had determined was a prosthetic leg
osteosarcoma sometimes takes a limb or
two to check you out than if it likes
you it takes the rest I followed him
upstairs losing ground as I made my way
up slowly stairs not being a field of
expertise for my lungs and then we were
out of Jesus's heart and in the parking
lot the spring air just on the cold side
of perfect the late afternoon light
heavenly in its hurtfulness mom wasn't
there yet which was unusual because mom
was almost always waiting for me I
glanced around and saw that at all curvy
brunette girl had Isaac pinned against
the stone wall of the church kissing him
rather aggressively they were close
enough to me that I could hear the weird
noises of their mouths together and I
could hear him saying always and her
saying always in return suddenly
standing next to me Augustus half
whispered they're big believers in PDA
what's with the always the slurping
sounds intensified
oh that's their thing they'll always
love each other and whatever I would
conservatively estimate that they have
texted each other the word always four
million times in the last year a couple
more cars drove up taking Michael and
ELISA away it was just a Gustus in me
now watching Isaac and Monica who
proceeded a pace as if they were not
leaning against an actual place of
worship his hand reached for her boob
over her shirt and pawed at it his palms
still while his fingers moved around I
wondered if that felt good didn't seem
like it would but I decided to forgive
Isaac on the grounds that he was going
blind the senses must feast while there
is yet hunger and whatever imagine
taking that last drive to the hospital I
said the last time you'll ever drive a
car without looking over at me Augustus
said
you're killing my vibe here hazel grace
I'm trying to observe young love and its
many splendored awkwardness 'as I think
he's hurting her boob I said yeah it's
difficult to ascertain whether he's
trying to arouse her or perform a breast
exam then Augustus waters reached into a
pocket and pulled out of all things a
pack of cigarettes he flipped it open
and put a cigarette between his lips are
you serious I asked you think that's
cool oh my god you just ruined the whole
thing which whole thing he asked turning
to me the cigarette dangled unlit from
the unsmiling corner of his mouth the
whole thing were a boy who is not
unattractive or unintelligent or
seemingly in any way unacceptable stares
at me and points out incorrect uses of
literality and compares me to actresses
and asks me to watch a movie at his
house but of course there is always a
hamartia
and yours is that oh my god even though
you had freaking cancer you give money
to a company in exchange to a in
exchange for the opportunity to acquire
yet more cancer oh my god let me just
assure you that not being able to
breathe sucks totally disappointing
totally AAHA Marsha
he asked the cigarette still in his
mouth it tightened his jaw he had a hell
of a jaw line unfortunately a fatal flaw
I explained turning away from him I
stepped toward the curb leaving Augustus
waters behind me and then I heard a car
start down the street it was mom she'd
been waiting for me to like make friends
or whatever I felt this weird mix of
disappointment and anger welling up
inside of me I don't even know what the
feeling was really just that there was a
lot of it and I wanted to smack Augustus
waters and also replace my lungs with
lungs that didn't suck at being lungs I
was standing with my Chuck Taylors on
the very edge of the curb the oxygen
tank ball and chaining in the cart by my
side and right his mom pulled up I felt
a hand grab mine I yanked my hand free
but turned back to him they don't kill
you unless you light them he said as mom
arrived at the curb and I've never
whipped one
it's a metaphor see you put the killing
thing right between your teeth but you
don't give it the power to do it's
killing
it's a metaphor I said dubious mom was
just idling it's a metaphor
he said you choose your behaviors based
on their metaphorical resonances I said
oh yeah he smiled the big goofy real
smile I'm a big believer in metaphor
hazel grace I turned to the car taps the
window it rolled down I'm going to a
movie with Augustus waters I said please
record the next several episodes of the
ANTM marathon for me that's the end of
chapter 1 um The Fault in Our Stars is
really it's the story of hazel and
Augustus and their attempt to come to
terms with that
soliloquy that hazel has it at the
beginning of the book they're about how
all of this will inevitably end in
Oblivion and they're their life together
and and their families and stuff that's
what the book is so I hope you guys
enjoyed the first chapter and I hope
that you like the the rest of the book
as well if and when you have the
opportunity to read it there are links
in the doobly-doo if you want to
preorder a signed copy all copies will
be signed before I go I will show you
the tibialis ometer ah tell you that I
have made significant progress I'm
actually very nearly up to 135,000 I
think although I haven't done a count
recently so just about 20,000 to go
maybe even a little less than 20,000
yeah I think just about like 15,000 to
go but I'm not positive I don't I I
don't know I should do a count it's
somewhere between 15 and 20 um but uh
thank you all so much for making it
possible for me to sign all of these
books and spend the last three months of
my life watching television and
listening to audiobooks and signing my
name over and over again it's been fun
I'm really grateful to all of you and I
will read and respond to comments this
is good this video is going to stay up
it's going to be my vlog brothers video
for the day but those of you who are
late I'm not getting punished because I
cleared this with Hank so I know that
it's longer than four minutes and it's
not edited or anything like that
but it is going to free up time so that
I can sign these remaining books which
is very very very very valuable to me
right now oh look it's Maureen Johnson
with her dirty dirty text messages
I was actually a really good that one of
Maureen Johnson's better dirty jokes
every time I do a live show even ones
that are going to live into perpetuity
Maureen Johnson sends me a dirty dirty
text message of some kind with some kind
of joke that I can never repeat because
they are so unfathomably filthy um so
anyway I hope you guys like The Fault in
Our Stars again there are pre-order
links below if you want to preorder a
signed copy certainly don't feel
obligated um but you know if you want to
I'm happy to sign a book for you I'm
going to sign them anyway so um I'm
happy if they go to a nice nerdfighter
nerd fight astok home instead of going
to like Target nothing I got target oh
god now targets going to be mad at me I
love you target you're like my favorite
of the two major big-box stores um so
anyway thank you guys so much and I'm
gonna make a joke now that's going to
make sense to very few of you but I'm
doing it as a favor to the person who
got me a paper jogger a nerdfighter gave
me a paper jogger which is watch out for
bears and I'm also going to say to all
of you an inside joke that you will get
French the llama for making my career
possible for the extraordinary gift that
you've given me by like watching this
video into its 36 minute and as always
don't forget to be awesome and best
wishes